all right so our next speaker needs
almost no introduction here uh somebody
I've known for about 10 I you know 10
years ago I was like hey I need to need
to do some art training called up our
studio I was like hey you know do you do
you know somebody they're like
yeah uh you know called you know art for
everyone um re really really fantastic
dude know worked with him quite a bit
and also interesting uh fact about him
he's an expert in Lacrosse loves ice
hockey and even plays curling but he is
not Canadian ladies and gentlemen Jared
Lander thank you very much thank
everyone for being here today we are
going to talk about a bunch of different
models and see which ones work best
we're going to do a model shootout
here so what are we going to model we
need data if we're going to model
something we need data to model so we
are going to use credit scoring data why
because we have it
and nothing has ever gone wrong from
giving someone a credit
score so our data looks roughly like
this we have a status column that is
good or bad and that's what we are
trying to predict whether you're good or
bad your whole life's going to boil down
to that and we have other input
variables such as senority what how if
you own your home or you rent it uh what
your marital status is your age all this
different stuff we're going to we're
going to predict that status that's the
goal so we're going to do we're going to
do this with a bunch of different model
types and see which one is best we will
look at penalized binary
regression decision
trees random forests boosted
trees boosted pseudo random forest and
neural networks and we're going to step
through each of these learn a little bit
about the math of them see what we have
to do and then we'll go and run them
all so how are we going to validate this
if we're going to say which one is is
the best we need a way to decide what is
best we need to decide on a metric so we
are going to use Au area under the curve
it's a nice number for binary
classification and essentially it's
between zero and one you want it closer
to one nice and easy to understand this
plot shows it right here sort of
summarizes it it's a balance between
false positives and true positives and
in this plot you want it drawn as close
to the top left as possible but we'll
get down to a number we will use cross
validation to tune the models and then
we will ultimately test the model on a
heldout test set and that whichever one
does the best has the best Au on the
heldout test set that is the winner all
right so let's start with penalized
binary regression you are trying to
solve this equation you're trying to
minimize this top equation it is log
loss which is another measure of how
wrong or good your model is subject to a
penalty that penalty the amount of
penalty is controlled by Lambda that's a
tuning parameter and then in the second
equation the PTY can be split between L1
loss or L2 loss you might also call
these Ridge uh lasso loss versus Ridge
loss and altogether penalize regression
you might also call it glim net or
elastic net there's lots of different
names the goal is to minimize this top
equation which really just comes down to
constrained quadratic optimization it's
a l gr it's a l Grange constant in there
so it's nice and easy to use there's a
bunch of feature engineering for the
basic stuff to get started you need to
make sure your class size is balanced
you don't want one class to be
completely different than another class
you need to impute missing data for that
means for numerics you need to fill in a
number for categorical data you could
just label it missing and that actually
works nicely you need to normalize your
numeric data so everything's on the same
scale you need to deal with unknown data
what happens when it comes to prediction
time and you have a level you haven't
seen before you have to deal with all
that and you have to convert your
categorical variables to dummies and you
need to include an intercept now of
course there's a lot more feature
engineering you can do for your specific
use case these are the basic you need
for this type of model so I've got to
show you some code I'm showing you the
best language in the world here I can't
show I can't not show code and these are
the steps you would take using the
recipes package to do all those steps
nine lines of code to do all that
feature engineering nice easy ready to
go now with all machine learning we have
tuning parameters the main ones for a
penalized regression in fact the only
two for the most implementations are the
amount of penalty how much you're going
to shrink your coefficients and what
type of penalty to mixture
and you can set those using the paret
package and here I'm actually only going
to tune penalty you'll see it says
penalty equals tune mixture I'm setting
to one because I don't want to bother
tuning it so it's purely lasso
regression purely L1 regression so
that's the penalized regression then we
come to decision trees decision trees
have been around forever they're
recursive partitioning really really
popular
algorithms and this is the equation for
it the idea is that you break up your
input space your feature space into a
bunch of discrete regions and then which
in each region whichever class is
predominant that's the predicted class
really simple equation the real magic of
this algorithm is how you create those
that space if you were Don Draper in the
60s you would create buckets
automatically by saying ages 18 to 24
and 25 to 35 but since we don't have Don
Draper we have machines tell us what
these regions
are feature engineering is a little
simpler here you need to make sure you
balance your class size and you need to
input impute missing data here we see
the steps similar to what we saw before
there's fewer of them now the main thing
is the down sampling and I'm doing down
sampling not upsampling that's something
we can discuss another time and I'm
imputing based on K nearest
neighbors tuning parameters there's also
only really two tuning parameters you
need tree depth which is how complex any
one tree can be and minimum node size
that is how many observations need to
fall in one of those regions in order to
make it a final region
and we could set that here with with uh
parsnip again again I'm only going to
tune one of them for the sake of time
I'm doing tree dep and I'm using the
party kit package because it should be
faster than the rart package it's a
nicer it's a faster package to use one
of the problems with decision trees
though is high variance and one of the
first attempts to get away from that is
a random Forest why fit one tree when
you can fit hundreds of
trees the idea is that you're going to
fit hundred
of independent trees each one randomly
built then average the predictions
together now if you're fitting a tree on
the same data set how do you make it
random there's two parts remember in
each tree you're asking a bunch of
questions is it bigger than this smaller
than that each time you're going to ask
a question instead of observing all the
rows of the data randomly sample half
the rows and ask the
question another thing decision trees do
is if you have 50 variables it examines
all 50 variables for each question and
says which is the best to make a split
on and it decides well here we are going
to constraint it to say here are
randomly chosen four variables which one
of those do you want to make the split
on so we've introduced two levels of
Randomness randomly selecting rows for
each tree and randomly choosing which
questions which columns you'll even
consider for each time you're asking a
question so it's a lot of
Randomness and random Force were
designed originally to not need to
oh we're not tuning we're doing future
engineering I'm sorry balance so the
things you have to do here is balance
the sample sizes and fill in missing
data you don't have to worry about dummy
variables just like with trees which is
really awesome so it's the same steps as
regular tree we saw this before same bit
of code we saw before so now get to the
tuning parameters that I was talking
about when you didn't need to tune it
Leo bryman designed this so you don't
need to tune them but we're going to
tune it
nonetheless we're going to look at how
many trees we want to average together
that's the number of trees we're going
to look at the minimum node size for
each tree the how many observations have
to be in a node and we will look at we
will try a bunch of different values of
how many randomly selected columns do we
want to examine for each
split we'll see here I going to tune
over M Tri which is the number of
columns and the number of trees and I'm
going to use the ranger package get it
forest
ranger gonna use that instead of the
random Forest Package because it should
run
faster another attempt to make trees
better is by boosting them now you can
boost anything right you could boost a
linear model in fact it was originally
called GBM which is gradient boosted
machines we just so happen to boost
trees today because that's just the best
it works the best right we're going
boosted trees and the equation is
deceptively
simple the prediction for the HRI tree
is the sum of all the previous
predictions right but that really does
not give it justice because each tree
learns from the previous trees when you
make when you make your first tree you
make your predictions well the next tree
learns from the mistakes of the previous
tree and gets better and it gets better
and better and better for all these
hundred trees but you end up averaging
everything together or summing them up
all together depending on your
perspective if you're averaging or
suming depending on how you formulate it
not really important
though what's nice about boosta trees at
least this implementation of it you
don't need to worry about the class size
you don't need to worry about balancing
the class sizes you don't need to impute
missing data but you do need to convert
your categorical data into dummy
variables so we're stuck with that but
hey no big deal we'll do that here
recipes we have even fewer steps because
we're not balancing the data nice simple
steps to do here but what you gain in
not having to do a lot of feature
engineering you make up for in tuning
parameters yeah there's tree depth
that's how complicated each individual
tree can get the number of trees is how
many rounds of boosting are you going to
go the learning rate is how fast to jump
to conclusions at each round the number
of
columns the minimum node size we saw
before minimum loss reduction that means
for each split in each tree how much
better the model needs to get sample
size is how many rows you want to sample
as a percentage and stopping iterations
it's early stopping like hey if this
isn't getting better after certain
rounds of boosting when should we stop
there's a lot you need to
consider I am just going to consider how
many rounds and how deep the tree should
get not going to worry about the rest
now remember I said you didn't need to
you didn't need to worry about class
balance that's because XG boost which is
what we're using handles class balance
for you you'll see that scale pause
weight if I just give it the ratio of
the overrepresented class with the
underrepresented class it calculates it
for you so I don't need to do any row
sampling it will do it for me and you
could use a different boosting algorithm
like light GBM which is actually by all
measures supposed to be better than XG
but everyone just keeps using XG boost
so that's what I'm going to do
and a nice other feature about XG boost
is that I can do it on the
GPU all I needed to change was the tree
method equals GPU hist and now the
GPU which is really nice you do need to
install the GPU version of the package
first but that's actually relatively
easy now thanks to a GitHub issue I
asked for like a few years ago I asked
them to build it automatically for us
and they said sure and they it's all
took very nice and easy them so then we
get to a boosted pseudo random Forest
you could boost your forests it's not a
true Forest that's why it's pseudo
you're basically combining the bagging
of random forest with the boosting of a
boosted tree the reason it's not a true
random Forest is because we are going to
sample The Columns to consider once per
tree not once per question per tree a
true random Forest would sample The
Columns at every question this is just
going to do it once per tree small
sacrifice so the again just like extr
boost there's no need to balance class
size no need to impute missing data but
you do need to convert your data to
dummies so same steps we saw before
nothing new here and the tuning
parameters are all the same as boost to
trees except there's one new one number
parallel trees if we're making a forest
how many trees do you want to do at one
time how many trees should be in your
Forest there we go all right oh I
skipped ahead nope that's it and my
clicker is not really going for me so
I'm going to skip the clicker for a
second here all right so this is what we
saw before same exact thing we saw as XG
boost we're going to use the GPU
everything else is going to be the same
in this case I'm going to take 50% of
the rows each time and I'm gonna for the
call sample by tree I'm just going to
set it to four I'm going to tune over
the number of parallel trees the number
of boosting rounds and the tree
depth on to neural networks everyone
wants to talk to about neural networks
have the time you talk to someone they
hear AI they think neural networks you
hear machine learning they think neural
networks this is a very simple
feedforward neural network it's
essentially just a series of linear
regressions with an activation function
in between something like a leaky relue
the idea here is you want to solve for
all the W's all the weights your
coefficients that's all it is it's just
using guess and checking essentially to
find those things it really you know I I
don't think it's as big a deal as people
make it is but if you get a really deep
and a really wide one you can do cool
stuff for the right type of data
so the feature engineering you need to
balance the class size need to imput
using data need to normalize your
predictors and you do need to convert
your categorical data into dummies or
better yet make it into an embedding all
right we're just going to take the
simple route here this is a step you've
seen before you've seen this for many
times there's more steps involved now
but there's not
done you need to then go ahead and build
a data loader I'm using torch here but
you can't just take your data and
transform it now the framework I've been
using so far par snip as part of
workflows theoretically that can fit a a
neural network but it wasn't working
well so I went straight into the torch
code so you have to do all these steps
just to get your data ready I'm not
going to talk about it I just want to
show it now the tuning parameters
there's a lot the number of layers the
number of nodes in each layer what how
much Dropout you're going to do on your
weights whether you're going to batch
normalize which activation function
you're going to use whether you're going
to sample your rows are you going to put
penalization in the form of weight Decay
there's a lot and to write this out you
don't have a nice interface you need to
create your neural network from scratch
you need to build up all your layers you
need to put them all together look how
much code this is taking and that's not
it you then need to formalize it you
need to set it up and get it all ready
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on here it's just too much work
all right so we have all of our
different models let's put them all
together let's draw the
dag I'm not running all these by hand
I'm putting them all together in a dag
and everything's going to go for us for
each model type it's going to do the
feature engineering it's going to to do
the tuning with cross validation it's
going to refit on the
trans the test data and evaluate the Au
this is our workflow all right this
comes from the targets package and when
I want to run all these steps I want all
these steps to happen I run this one
line of
code yeah it's like it's like make but
for R specifically it's great and it
could run all your steps in parallel now
you do have to be careful because some
of our algorithms run in parallel
already so you don't want to do parallel
within parallel what's really cool is at
least of XG boost I can do the cross
validation in parallel and CPU and have
all the fitting happen on the GPU in
parallel again that's really awesome all
right let's see how our models did it's
time we fit all our models it ran really
quickly maybe maybe not and we will see
how each of our models did we're going
to compare a for all of them in a nice
simple bar
chart and we see very quickly that the
boosted pseudo random Forest is the best
barely
right all of them are
roughly good traffic all of them are
roughly the
same but a plain old tree is a little
bit worse it's a little bit worse than
all of them and notice there's actually
a difference between the booster Tre and
the CPU and the GPU that's probably a
little bit of Randomness so we're not
going to worry about that and notice I'm
not showing the neural network it's Au
was
0.5 so I'm not if I made it more layers
i t it longer and spent a lot of money
in GPU time I could have got it better
but it just wasn't worth my effort to do
that for tabular data if I were doing
Vision data or text or audio maybe
neural network would have been better
but for this tabular data wasn't worth
my
time but now let's see how long the
models took to fit so that's an
important part of the
conversation the boosted pseudo random
Forest took a lot of time 12
hours yeah now that's not just fitting
that's the cross validation and
everything thing but I wasn't doing that
much cross validation either so let's
take out the random Forest the boosted
forest and see did it's a lot easier to
see the linear model was the fastest
about four seconds that includes the
cross validation and the tuning that's
pretty good the slowest was a regular
Forest at about six minutes that's a lot
better than 12 hours right so we really
want to find the Paro Optimum of
performance and speed so we plot them
together we can see here that the pseudo
random Forest is just throwing off the
scale so let's take it out and see this
again and now we can see it very quickly
it looks like both the linear model and
the boosted GPU model are the best of
both worlds they're both accurate and
they're fast while a single tree was
faster than a booster tree his
performance is so much worse that why
bother and we can see here that the
boosted GPU and the CPU versus CPU the
GPU is faster and since it was
technically a little bit more accurate
random maybe let's just go with that one
right that's their best model that
linear or boosted GPU the
best but there's one more
thing I want to Ensemble all the models
I want to stick them all together we are
going to fit a weighted average of the
different models we're going to compute
the weights by taking our true outcome
variable and regressing that with
penalized regression against the out
come from all of the models and then see
which ones should be weighted more
heavily than
others we do that with this simple eight
lines of Code by taking all of our
models we had fit earlier combining them
together but I'm not just combining
these six models I'm actually combining
all the different versions of each of
the models so if I have for a single
Model 50 different parameter
combinations I'm actually ensembling
those 50 models with the 50 for the
other type and the other type so I'm
actually ensembling hundreds of models
and seeing which ones are are best
together and when we do that this shows
us the combined weights for each model
type so the boosted pseudo random forest
was used three times in our Ensemble and
had a combined weight of four which is
nearly double all the other ones
combined no it's the same as all the
other ones combined it's more than all
the ones combined more barely more and
so it had the highest combined weight it
got used the most so that was the most
contributive and I don't even know if
that's a real word but the most
contributive to our Ensemble model was
this boosted random forest and now what
we're going to do is we're going to get
predictions from all these models
combined and see how and see how they
did on the test set and compute the Au
and we see that the Ensemble is indeed
the best we had slightly a little bit
better right but keep in mind though
that Ensemble included that boosted
random Forest which took 12 hours to run
so I you know what let's do it again but
leave out the boosted random forest and
we see the slightly smaller Ensemble
model was just about as good it's better
than theud random Forest by itself it's
better than everything else and it's
almost as good as the full Ensemble
model so you know what I'm just going to
do that I'm going to fit everything
except for the neural network and except
for the boosted random forest and
Ensemble them together since the
ensembling process added about like
another minute to the process that's
what I'm going to go for
there so all that we learned a lot of
different things we learned some math we
learned some code so besides the math
and tuning parameters what do we get
from
this linear models are fast and they're
performant sometimes just go of a linear
model be done of your life and move on
to the next
problem booster trees are a little bit
better especially if you use the GPU
then things are
great and we saw that we needed to
balance the performance with the speed
one without the other is no good you
need both but in reality we're going to
do what we're do and throw everything
against the wall and see what sticks and
if you really want something good you're
just gonna combine them all together
that's the key thing throw everything
combine them all together thank you very
much